i hate intros moriarty the patriots
season one episode one we kick things
off one night when a young boy is
abducted and
killed this is the seventh incident
where a young boy is the target we then
get an introduction to the main
character in william james moriarty he
of course took an interest in the case
and is discussing it with his younger
brother in louise james moriarty
after reading up on the case a little
bit in the paper william had discovered
similarities amongst the victims
all of the victims fathers worked in
places where nobles would have to go in
person because they are unable to send
the servants
with that little piece of information he
could deduce that the culprit is
actually a nobleman we then hop on over
to a new face in albert james moriarty
who goes to visit the most recent
victim's father
he knows the man so he gives his
condolences for his fallen son but aside
from that nothing really happens
later on moriarty comes across a boy who
is trying to play an instrument but
isn't very good at it william takes him
out to eat and the kid explains that he
had gotten the instrument from a fallen
victim
and wanted the crimes when he goes to
see where the boy is playing he notices
a window that would have a nice vantage
point over the whole plaza when he
follows up this hunch he finds the earl
of
argleton sitting at the window he
approaches the man to talk with him and
quickly notices that he has
items from the shops where all of the
victims had worked after he is found out
the earl sends a henchman after william
to take care of him william of course
sees this coming and luis helps subdue
the man so they can question him they
used the information that they got from
the henchmen to abduct and detain the
earl albert's friend and the most recent
victim's father is then given his chance
to exact revenge on the earl so he stabs
him to death with a pair of scissors
episode 2. we then hop back a bit to
when william was a kid
even back then he was much smarter than
all of the adults and had great insight
along with analysis
we then learned that william and his
brother louise were adopted into the
moriarty family
william isn't even his real name the
original william was albert's
blood-related brother we then hop back
even more to where albert had first laid
eyes on william
or whatever the [ __ ] his name is him and
his brother were living at an orphanage
where he impressed
everybody around him with his intellect
we then hop on over to albert's father
who was manipulated by a blonde with meg
tits into adopting an
orphan out of charity his father's
trying to [ __ ] the blonde so he sent
albert to the orphanage to pick some out
when he got there he saw william talking
with some adults
he had given the men a plan to break
into a safe that had money from poor
people after they were extorted
albert put two and two together that
that's what they were talking about but
didn't fully believe it yet
his suspicions are confirmed when he
overhears william telling all the kids
to fight and kill nobles because they
are unjust
albert saw the way his family had
treated lower class people with william
even stabbing a woman
in the hand just because he wanted to
this makes him realize that hey maybe
this guy is making a lot of good points
so he invites him and louise to stay at
the moriarty mansion
episode three when they arrive at the
mansion william and louise quickly
realized that they're not
going to be treated well here because
even the [ __ ] butler simon wants to
make things hard for them luis is sickly
and often struggles so william tries to
make things as easy as possible for his
brother
then one day luis is targeted by william
which is the little [ __ ] not his
brother
little [ __ ] wants his tea so he has
louise get him some but then dumps it on
the ground and says that he would never
drink it because he was the one that
made it he also decides that luis is
responsible for making the mess and he
wants him to clean it up with his tongue
this is when william steps in and offers
to clean it in louise's place
instead of cleaning it the little [ __ ]
changes his mind and decides that he
needs to stab himself with a fork to
ensure that it's not going to happen
again
william is kind of a badass so he stabs
himself in the hand with a fork and
remains emotionless
little fucker's kind of sadistic so he's
disappointed that he didn't cry out in
pain or whatever but that's all that
comes with that we see that albert is
getting increasingly annoyed with how
badly his family treats the lower class
one night little [ __ ] decides that he
wants to frame william and louise for
stealing silverware that way they get
thrown out william is two steps ahead of
him and is ready to deal justice to him
it won't be him delivering the justice
though it will actually be albert
because let's face it he's kind of sick
of the little [ __ ] [ __ ] albert takes a
broken piece of wood and stabs his
brother with
it his intention isn't to kill him
though because they need it to look like
an accident william louise and albert
then stage a house fire to make it look
like that's how the family died the
three boys are the only quote unquote
survivors in the fire which is when
william took on his new identity
episode 4. we again jump back into the
past where we see
a man named burton with his wife
michelle and their sick baby
their baby has a fever and it is quickly
getting worse so they come to the vice
count of belford to get help they have
no one else to rely on because their
normal doctor is away attending his
daughter's wedding the vi count has a
doctor of his own but he refuses to let
them see him because they are in the
lower class
since he had refused to help them the
baby ends up dying
meanwhile william and louise had just
moved in nearby because william had
taken a job as a college professor
the vikout then invites the three
brothers to dinner while attending the
dinner they learned that the vi count
has a heart condition so he can't drink
too much and is on a medication called
kineen
the blood count has a hobby of
collecting rare plants and burton is the
one who tends to them we get a quick
shot
burton heading back to his house where
we learned that michelle is still very
distraught over the loss of her son
while burton is drinking out of pub
william then comes in and talks to him
william plants the seat of revenge and
burden so burton hires him as a
consultant to carry out the murder the
three brothers then head back to the vi
counts mansion where they offer him some
marmalade on crackers
the marmalade is made from grapefruit so
michelle and burton are nearby cutting
up some more it appears as though
michelle snaps and rushes the vike out
with a knife
spurn then gets to her and stops her
from killing him but then the vike
count's heart starts acting up
they quickly get his medication to calm
him down and then he fires the two of
them
after she had just tried kill him once
they're gone the vibe count realizes
that he's still not feeling too good
turns out that the grapefruit is
preventing his medicine from working
correctly
this causes him to die while making it
look like it was natural causes
in the last couple of scenes we see that
the brothers had helped burton and his
wife get work at queen mary's garden
episode 5. moriarty had noticed that one
of his students
lucian atwood had been missing for three
days
william goes to talk with lucian's
roommate tate to see if he knows
anything about it during their talk
william learns that lucian was dating a
waitress named freda
while william is following this up we
then get a new face
in dudley bale who encourages william to
leave the case alone
after the conversation he continues on
to the pub that tate had mentioned frida
works at he talks with a woman who works
there who informs him that frida had
died
a man had seen her dancing and singing
on top of a bridge until she fell into
the water and drown
she also tells him that lucian had
proposed marriage to her even though she
wasn't in the upper class
on top of that she was also pregnant
with lucian's kid
soon after a man stops by and tells
frida that lucian was no longer
interested in being with her after
hearing that she supposedly threw
herself off the bridge to commit suicide
it's revealed that dudley was actually
the one responsible for killing frida he
is also keeping lucian inside of brothel
where he's drug to the point where he
can't do anything
meanwhile william decides to employ the
help of two men in sebastian morgan and
fred pollock fred had went and got
lucian and brought him to the bridge
where frida had died mildly runs up to
him asking if he had summoned him there
it's revealed that dudley had killed
freda because he didn't want the
upperclassman lucian marrying into some
lower class woman like her
we then see frida come walking up out of
the river dudley is confused of course
because he is the one that pumped her
full of opium and then threw her into
the river where she died
this gives them the confession they were
looking for and it's revealed that frida
is actually fred in disguise
after doing some digging william had
learned that dudley has a chain of
brothels as well as opiate dens
he would then lure in students of
aristocrats to indulge in their bad
habits and then turn around and
blackmail their parents into giving him
money in exchange for his silence
turns out sebastian is a sniper with a
pretty good shot so he shoots at
dudley's feet trying to make him dodge
until he falls into the river and drowns
episode 6. some poor bastard is targeted
by a crazy hunter who sets dogs on him
and then shoots and kills him we then
see the killer count blitz enders who's
trying to board a cruise ship called the
noetic
following the common theme amongst the
killers he hates all of the lower class
and wishes that they weren't on board
moriarty has obviously picked up on what
this guy's been up to which is why he's
tailing him and going on the cruise also
while boarding early a man in the lower
class yells at blitz and tells him to
get in line and the two share a bit of
an altercation
we say that moriarty's overall goal is
to expose the public to the heinous
crimes that the upper class are
committing against the lower class
focusing around death by doing this he
hopes to change the minds of men
and open their eyes to the injustice and
the skewed balance of power
in their society blitz is a colossal
dick and terrorizes everybody in his
path if they are in the lower class
we then see that the man who caused
blitz some problems while boarding is
named thomas michelson
and is actually working for sebastian to
annoy blitz as much as possible he's a
habitual criminal so he's committed rape
and murder and not
exactly a stand-up guy thomas is then
approached by blitz who says that he
wants to smooth things over
after their little altercation while
boarding this is a lie and once thomas
is alone blitz attacks him and stabs him
to death
everything is going according to plan
for moriarty so he comes in and
witnesses the body along with blitz
episode 7 william pretends to be on his
side and says that the best course of
action is to just throw the body
overboard however when they do that the
others are waiting on a lower deck and
catch
the body before it falls into the water
there's a big ballet performance going
on on the cruise so many of the
passengers go to attend during an
intermission william approaches blitz
and points out that the man he had
killed is actually in the crowd blitz
runs down to confront the man but when
he gets there the man is gone
he finds out the general direction that
thomas may have went and chases after
him with everything going according to
plan he then comes across the body of
the murdered man let's begin stabbing
the body to ensure that it's actually
dead
as he's doing this fred pulls a lever
that raises him up to the stage where
everybody can see him stabbing the man
there have been rumors of blitz leading
people onto his ground so he could hunt
them down and kill him but nobody ever
believed it until now with their
suspicions confirmed
everybody in the crowd starts to turn on
him so blitz kind of doubles down and
says that this is subhuman life and he
deserve to die he then gets into a
screaming match with one of the guys in
the crowd and lunges at him with the
knife
luckily a mysterious man steps in to
deter the attack and sends blitz running
this man then goes up to the body of
thomas and starts analyzing it hop back
on over to blitz who is running from the
authorities because there's so many
places to run on a cruise ship he
eventually finds himself climbing his
way to freedom on the deck of the ship
sebastian then shoots him with a bb gun
causing him to lose his grip
and he falls into the ocean after
everything was concluded we see that
william and the others all get together
to discuss what had happened
everything had gone as planned but there
is one little problem the mysterious man
that had deterred blitz's attack and
then studied the body of thomas
approaches william after they had
disembarked the cruise ship he points
out to william that the man who had died
had been dead for a while and that it
wasn't a recent kill like the stabbing
had suggested
he also deducted that there must be a
third party involved that led bullets to
believe that the man wasn't dead before
he had stabbed him in the last couple of
scenes as william is walking away we
finally get the man's name
and the official introduction of
sherlock holmes
episode 8. apparently sherlock isn't
doing so hot in terms of money so he's
approached by miss hudson who was
looking for her rent money during their
little argument one of sherlock's
friends named stamford recognizes them
and approaches him once he's filled in
on the situation he suggests that
sherlock get a flatmate so he can split
right with them after trying and failing
with a couple of different candidates he
finally gets miss hudson to agree to one
of them his name is john h
watson and he was a doctor in the afghan
war while they're getting to know each
other over some drinks the three of them
are then approached by the inspector of
scotland yard
named lestrade the inspector informs him
that count trevor had been murdered and
that there was a letter laying next to
the body that read sherlock so he has to
put sherlock under arrest
while they're escorting him we then get
another new character in gregson who
doesn't exactly see eye-to-eye with
sherlock there are footprints at the
scene of the crime that match sherlock's
boots as well as rounds fired from a gun
that was the same caliber as sherlock's
gun
sherlock and watson are then brought to
the scene of the crime so that they
could investigate the body
the first thing that sherlock points out
is that his name couldn't have been
written by the count because his fingers
weren't thick enough
it's also apparent that the spread of
the bullets makes it likely that the
assailant wasn't exactly good with
firearms in conclusion he decides that
the count was murdered by an amateur but
somebody was behind it all pulling the
strings while everybody is talking
sherlock subtly passes a no along to
watson
then in the last couple of scenes we see
that it was indeed william orchestrating
everything as he convinces the man to
carry out his plan
episode 9. sherlock requests less trade
let him escape so that he can find the
real culprit the straight acts like he
loses control of his horse which gives
sherlock an opening to make a run for it
after he had escaped he goes to meet
with watson
the note he had passed to watson was
actually a plan saying that he was going
to plan his escape with the inspector
and that they were to meet
up sherlock then reveals that while at
the scene he had found a ring there the
ring belongs to the killer and he is
desperate to get it back they then put
an ad
in the paper saying that they had found
a ring under watson's name william and
the others already know that it's likely
a trap but they decide to send fred
anyways
a little old woman comes to watson and
says that her daughter is the owner of
the ring so he returns it to her
sherlock then trails a woman to see
where she's going and if she meets with
anybody
the old woman is actually fred in
disguise and when he makes a break for
it him and sherlock wind up getting into
a fight fred is able to fight sherlock
off and manages to escape sherlock was
able to find out that the ring belonged
to a woman named lucy who was killed
meaning that the culprit must be her
husband because he had her wedding ring
after she had passed away
the man who killed the cow is named
jefferson hope and is actually their cab
driver the motivation for hope killing
the count was because the count had
murdered his wife the killing was
supposed to be done with more finesse to
make it seem like sherlock was the
culprit but once hope had seen the man
who had killed his wife he lost his cool
and things got messy
a deal is suggested between hope and
sherlock where hope says that if
sherlock shoots and kills him then fred
who is nearby will come and tell
sherlock who the real mastermind is
hope is dying anyways because he's sick
so he doesn't mind getting shot but of
course sherlock disagrees because he
wants to solve the mystery by himself
without somebody just telling him the
answer
instead he takes hope into custody and
uses him to clear his name for the
murder
episode 10. after it's made public that
sherlock had solved the murder his
consulting business began to get more
and more cases which he easily solves
you'd think he's more happy now that
he's getting more business but he's
still hung up on who tried to frame him
he's starting to become obsessed with
not knowing so he gets desperate to find
new leads with nothing to go on he asks
lestrade to tell him about any
aristocrat deaths that have happened
recently
this leads him to investigate the vi
counts death that was caused by the
grapefruit the story was that the vice
count was out walking when he had
succumbed to his illness
they all go to investigate the scene but
can't seem to find any clues
it even gets to the point where sherlock
gets mad at watson for not letting him
kill the man before so he could know who
set him up the two of them get in a
fight right before they board a train to
go back to london
well on the train sherlock spots luis
and williams sitting nearby so he goes
to join them
out of nowhere sherlock then accuses
william of being the culprit mastermind
behind everything williams says that he
can't prove that he wasn't involved and
that the burden of proof is on sherlock
sherlock then says that he's just
kidding about his accusation but he does
find the thought of william being behind
it kind of entertaining
william kind of goes along with this and
playfully says catch me if you can
in the last couple of scenes we see that
there was another murder on board the
train
sherlock suggests that him and william
have a contest to see who can find the
culprit first
then out of nowhere watson comes walking
up with blood all over him
episode 11. the police arrive and want
to take jon into custody because he's
covered in blood
john explains that he didn't know the
blood was there and had bumped into
somebody when he was coming out of the
bathroom louise talks with william where
we learned that the culprit has nothing
to do with them
that aside william is still interested
in the contest so he wants to find the
culprit
also after investigating the body the
two conclude that the victim was a
jeweler and the culprit tried to drug
and rob him
even though he was drugged he woke up in
the middle of the robbery and decided to
fight back and during the fight he was
stabbed and killed they also realized
that the culprit is likely one of the
staff members so they round everybody up
after going over everybody's shoe size
they seem to have found the culprit when
he has blood all over his gloves he says
that the blood is his and he was injured
during the job
it's likely that he's lying but they
have nothing else that implicates him
william then steps in and noticed some
blood splattered on the guy's glasses
this prompts the guy to confess that he
was trying to rob him but it wasn't his
intention to kill him the blood on his
glasses was actually planted there by
william
william knew it was a staff member but
wasn't sure which one so he had cut his
finger and planted blood on all of them
this ensured that the resolution to the
case would have come sooner than later
when watson is released him and sherlock
go out for a drink where sherlock asks
him to continue working with him as his
partner
and in the last couple of scenes we get
introduced to a new character in
minecraft homes
he is reporting to the queen about some
documents that have gone missing
she says that these documents are of the
utmost importance and he can use any
means
necessary to get them back which will
likely segue into the next season i'm
going to be doing the future seasons and
you can find that on the left side
whenever i'm finished with it or you can
check out all the more yardy the patriot
recaps in the playlist on the right side
you can also find the links in the
description below and the only thing i
hate more than intros is
outros